bonsoir et bienvenue dans kiosque votre
émission culturelle aux sommaire ce soir
le festival Blues sur scène du 7 au 22
novembre ce sont 31 communes 70 groupes
sans lieu 150 événements et pour en
parler dans quelques instants Arnaud bel
le directeur du festival La Commanderie
des Templiers à Élancourt le premier
dimanche de chaque mois le musée de la
ville de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
propose de découvrir la richesse de ce
lieu érigé au 12ème siècle et puis dans
sa chronique du collège
la troupe de danse hip-hop 5 continents
faite ses 30 ans cette année rencontre
avec Christine Gaudin voilà le menu
culturel du kiosque de ce mercredi 5
novembre
et on démarre tout de suite avec la
commanderie des Templiers à Élancourt le
premier dimanche de chaque mois le musée
de la ville de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
propose de découvrir la richesse de ce
lieu érigé au 12e siècle nous avons
assisté il y a quelques jours à une
visite à deux voies qui mêle patrimoine
arts visuel ou de faire Richie Elodie
moine
d'un côté une chapelle un bâtiment des
gardes et une ancienne écurie de l'autre
une exposition temporaire sur le paysage
pour trois artistes en résidence le
point de départ d'une visite à deux
voies de la commanderie des Templiers
lorsque le patrimoine trouve un écho
dans l'art lorsque l'histoire du site
trouve ses racines dans la richesse
naturelle de l'environnement à l'époque
des Templiers c'était une zone rurale
donc il n'y avait pas toutes les
constructions il n'y avait pas les
routes tout autour vous avez beaucoup de
forêts et l'importance du lieu en fait
tient à son point d'eau un ordre
templier enfin un ordre religieux ne va
pas s'installer dans un endroit isolé
s'il n'existe pas un point d'accès à
l'eau pour pouvoir subvenir à ses
propres besoins
loin des villes les moines trouvées ici
le silence nécessaire à leur prière tout
en enseignant la recchestre l'art de la
chevalerie bien avant l'urbanisation
intensive de ces 40 dernières années
que vous retrouvez partout en France et
même dans les traces d'archives on parle
de la commanderie de la ville lieu mais
on ne sait pas de quelle ville Dieu il
s'agit
les Templiers ça c'est un petit peu
rêver on pense au grand maudit on pense
à ce qu'on a écouté travers des séries
télé au travers des livres au travers de
l'histoire qu'on connaît quand même un
petit peu avec justement ce mélange avec
les croisades le mélange de l'Orient et
de l'Occident c'est joli c'est bien
refaire et ça nous redonne un petit peu
une idée de de ce que pouvait être la
Commanderie au 13e ou 14e siècle la
Commanderie est en cours reste la seule
trace de cet ordre religieux militaire
toujours visible aujourd'hui en
Île-de-France rénovée dans les années 70
et 2000 elle ouvre ses portes au public
chaque premier dimanche du mois
l'exposition elle est accessible tout au
long de la semaine en décembre et en
avril la visite à deux voies sur la
thématique des paysages sera décliné sur
celle des saisons
allez trois dates d'agenda retenir la
compagnie de la bobine propose un
spectacle samedi soir intitulé Mara sad
à la ferme de Coville de
Voisins-le-Bretonneux une confrontation
entre deux personnages de la Révolution
le Market sad le sulfureux et
Jean-Baptiste Marat assassiné en 1793 du
théâtre aussi sur la scène nationale
dans la République du bonheur c'est
samedi soir une critique jubilatoire et
sans concession de la tyrannie du
bonheur dans nos sociétés mondialisées
tout un programme et puis après avoir
foulé les scènes parisiennes elles nous
présente de drôles de voisins dans son
nouveau spectacle s'est arrivé près de
chez elle Julie Alibert est seul sur
scène à la Royal Factory tous les
samedis jusqu'au 15 novembre Aurélia
Debussy et William elles l'ont croisé je
vous propose un extrait de leur
rencontre elle nous parle de son
spectacle
et bah c'est Julie qui a moi donc qui a
un rêve c'est de faire son spectacle de
beatbox et bon il s'avère que Julie est
un peu ringarde et elle est issue d'une
famille d'artistes un petit peu rouillée
ça sa grand-mère était poète sa mère
contorsionniste oui oui et tout ça se
passe dans un immeuble vous composez
avec 5 personnages toutes les
générations sont présentées du jeune
enfant à la personne plus âgée est-ce
que vous avez parfois des difficultés à
les interpréter alors je pense par
exemple difficulté en tout genre je
pense à la contorsionniste dont vous
nous parliez à cette mère
contorsionniste là il a fallu quand même
vous enfiliez un déguisement pas très
très près du corps
est-ce que c'est pas difficile ça par
exemple
mettre un peu en danger comme ça
non parce que ça me fait rire ça me fait
rire et à partir du moment ça me fait
rire et ben je vais en jouer et vu que
j'ai pas encore de top model et ben
c'est d'autant plus drôle et
non je trouve je trouve l'exercice
périlleux parce que c'est vrai que elle
est extrêmement souple
elle dégage quelque chose de très félin
et du beatbox galère ça donne quoi du
beatbox galère
ça fait
sur la scène de la Royal Factory tous
les samedis soirs jusqu'au 15 novembre à
notre entretien retrouvé dans son
intégralité sur le site internet de
tvfils 78 et prochainement dans le
kiosque
dans sa chronique Nicolas Gervais part à
la rencontre des blacks blanc Blur la
troupe de danse hip-hop 58 mois se fête
ses 30 ans cette année rencontre avec
Christine Coudun
compagnie historique de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et pionnière
de la danse hip-hop en Europe elle fête
ses 30 ans cette année avec notamment
travelling à découvrir les 21 et 22
novembre prismaël en cours et le 17
décembre paradoxe à la Meuse à Trappes
voici donc les blacks blancs beurre et
leur chorégraphe Christine Coudin dans
le kiosque c'est surtout les
perspectives d'avenir qui font le poids
de ces 30 dernières années parce que si
on revient sur le passé on a quand même
beaucoup de retours positifs là il va y
avoir un rassemblement de danseurs et
toutes les tous les gens qui nous ont
connu à différentes étapes de notre de
notre vie en vie nouvelle surtout et
dans la région donc ça on va en mesurer
le poids quand on va on va vraiment se
rencontrer donc voilà après le mythe
c'est quand même quelque chose
d'extérieur c'est les gens qui vivent le
mythe de B3 c'est pas moi
j'ai fait le choix donc de
d'illustrer en perspective notre
répertoire et j'ai sélectionné une
dizaine de spectacles sur l'ensemble du
répertoire et à partir de ces 10
spectacles différents je déconstruis un
peu je choisis des extraits et je les
monte dans un ordre qui n'est pas
forcément chronologique
il y aura des extraits de si je t'aime
enfin ça dépend dans l'ordre peut-être
il y a des extraits de raptipa qui est
un spectacle assez ancien il y a un
spectacle de contrepied contre-pied
c'est le premier spectacle que j'ai
signé dans la glandeur
on l'a créé en 1990 entre temps on
l'avait remonté parce qu'il avait été
coproduit en Autriche mais voilà c'est
quand même un travail très très ancien
contre Pierre un petit pas son présent
parce qu'ils ont beaucoup tourné
on a beaucoup tourné à l'étranger avec
ça avec contre-pied on a abordé les
continents comme l'Afrique donc tous les
spectacles aussi que je garde ils ont
ils sont aussi porteurs d'une grande
valeur de la vie de B3 du symbole et
donc de la qualité artistique donc ça
c'est le principe
après j'ai essayé dans le montage dans
la manière d'amener les extraits de de
respecter certaines caractéristiques de
la compagnie à savoir la mixité de
l'effectif le fait que je travaillais
essayé de travailler avec les filles
avec les garçons sur le thème du couple
donc tout ça va être va être présent
il va y avoir des représentants de oui
des quatre générations de l'autre côté
il y a les B3 juniors donc ça c'est la
dernière génération on présente un
spectacle à la Merise en décembre
une longue collaboration
avec avec train en fait c'est
l'aboutissement de trois ans de travail
avec cette avec cette équipe de danseurs
c'est une évolution c'est un processus
donc pour transmettre les valeurs de
fond sur le travail chorégraphique sur
la création sur comprendre qu'est-ce que
c'est qu'un artiste qu'est-ce que c'est
de composer qu'est-ce que c'est de
chorégraphié comment on peut travailler
son propre solo c'est toutes ces
questions qui se posent et c'est des
réponses que j'amène mais c'est aussi
l'expérience ensemble qui est construit
des réponses pour pour les danseurs et
puis c'est une construction collective
au thème c'est les danseurs de B3
juniors qui ont choisi le thème donc
c'est la relation entre les riches et
les pauvres donc c'est une thématique
très proche de l'actualité finalement
donc ensemble on a on a développé les
éléments dramaturgiques de ce spectacle
et vraiment ils ont mis leur cœur ils
restent
Nicolas on va maintenant parler du
festival Blues sur scène 16e édition
avec vous Arnaud belbonsoin vous en êtes
le directeur je l'ai dit en début de
cette émission blue sur scène c'est
d'abord 31 communes qui participent 31
salle qui ouvre leur porte il y a 70
groupes attendus 150 événements à la
fois c'était c'est des concerts c'est
aussi des expositions des spectacles
jeunes publics des rencontres musicales
des créations des actions culturelles 16
ans que ça dure et c'est aussi fort
depuis 16 ans au départ il y avait que
si commune attends vous êtes trente une
commune du Val de Seine à participer
donc on est très très content d'ailleurs
le public aussi suit puisqu'on est de
plus en plus nombreux à suivre le
festival donc oui oui c'est un festival
qui se développe qui se développe chaque
année un petit peu pourquoi sur le Val
de Seine avoir eu l'idée de créer ce
festival il y a 16 ans autour du blues
parce que déjà il y avait pas grand
chose au mois de novembre qui se passe
souvent les festivals on les voit plutôt
l'été nous on avait envie de
l'association
blue sur scène puisque c'est un festival
porté par une association avait souhaité
faire un événement vraiment sur le mois
de novembre et puis aussi autour du
blues puisque le blues est une musique
matrice d'énormément d'autres musiques
donc ça permet de parler à énormément de
petites choses peut-être mais on pense
au gospel on pense au rock au rock n'
roll puis au rock au passé au RnB mais
on pense aussi au hip-hop avec beaucoup
de liens qui sont entre le blues et le
hip-hop et qui sont qui sont très très
proches finalement
on va parler on va pas pouvoir dire tous
les invités qui sont présents parce
qu'il y en a beaucoup il y a des
pointures il y a des groupes qui
viennent qui sont un peu nouveaux on a
envie de dire entre nouvelle génération
c'est comme ça que vous voulez vous les
appelez je crois mais je vous propose
déjà de voir un extrait de certains des
invités
alors voyez beaucoup d'artistes
différents beaucoup d'Américains comment
on fait venir des Américains comme ça du
côté de du Val de Seine
on a souvent d'ailleurs tendance à
penser que le blues et américain mais il
a des origines africaines il a même des
origines européennes à travers pas mal
de ses instruments donc on a on a une
programmation certes avec des artistes
américains mais aussi des artistes
européens des artistes venus d'un petit
peu partout d'Afrique etc
pour répondre à la question plus
précisément comment faire venir des
artistes américains mais déjà on les on
les cherche donc on a toujours un petit
rôle de découvrir de talent aller
rechercher les talents ou teatlantiques
on s'informe beaucoup et puis ensuite on
fait toutes les démarches aussi
administratives pour les faire venir une
fois qu'on a fait le choix des artistes
et les démarches administratives pour
qu'ils viennent pour qu'ils puissent
venir travailler en France
70 artistes du 7 au 22 novembre 31
communes 31 salles c'est organisation de
fou c'est une organisation assez
importante parce que on peut rajouter
qui a 100 lieux différents donc on est
sur 150 événements sur 15 jours donc ça
fait énormément d'événements par jour
donc effectivement il y a un puzzle
assez ardu à monter assez compliqué et
avec plein de de problématiques mais
mais voilà ça se fait ça se fait mais
bien souvent ça se fait sur un peu plus
d'un an puisque on anticipe déjà
l'édition 2015 alors qu'on est en train
de parler 2014
mais est-ce qu'on peut en citer
quelques-uns ou en tout cas mettre un
petit coup de projecteur sur certains
qui qui arrive donc dès la semaine
prochaine puisque ça sera le lundi 10
alors pourquoi programmer un lundi 10
c'est parce que c'est la veille d'un
jour férié donc voilà on pourra y sortir
sans appréhension c'est un c'est email
d'amey email dames c'est un peu la reine
du rockabilly
l'Union européenne qui est très reconnue
aux États-Unis et qui est très reconnu
aussi pour avoir joué avec Van Morrison
Jeff Beck
Eric Clapton etc tout le monde l'a
considère un petit peu comme une une des
grandes stars du style elle sera
accompagnée enfin elle sera précédée sur
scène par igitte qui nous avait fait qui
avait été une belle découverte de
l'édition précédente du festival qui
jouera en première partie depuis il a
été découvert par une émission bien
connue sur une grande chaîne de
télévision nationale donc il dit et
email dames ça sera la nacelle à
Aubergenville le lundi 10 autrement il y
a aussi d'énormes il y a aussi beaucoup
d'autres spectacles on a la chance de
faire venir Sharon Jones cette année
donc c'est de la grande dame de la santé
exactement le 15 novembre à Mantes pour
une soirée à pas rater puisque c'est la
grande grande dame de la soul
américaine et il reste des places il
faut il faut se précipiter les prendre
c'est un peu un mélange entre Tina
Turner et James Brown si vous voulez sur
scène donc c'est vraiment un événement à
pas louper et puis il y a aussi une
soirée à Vernouillet avec le héritage
blues Orchestra dont on a entendu
quelques notes tout à l'heure ça sera le
21 novembre exactement et ça c'est un
très très beau voyage entre les musiques
justement américaines et les musiques
européennes puisqu'il y a un vrai
croisement avec neuf musiciens sur scène
c'est vraiment aussi un concert à ne pas
manquer donc pour se concernement
ok en gros il y a un tarif impasse si on
veut assister à plusieurs
mais ça nous permet d'aller à tous les
concerts du festival pendant les 15
jours donc évidemment c'est très très
rentable
il faut pouvoir sortir un petit peu
souvent et autrement le prix moyen du
festival est très très accessible
puisqu'on est à peu près à 10 euros de
tarif moyen sur le festival après il y a
aussi beaucoup de choses qui sont
gratuites comme des concerts dans des
bars dans des restaurants des
expositions sur le site internet qui
s'affichent merci beaucoup Arnaud parler
de ce festival donc blues sur scène
c'est du 7 au 22 novembre et puis aussi
pour votre information faut savoir que
tes fils sont dix partenaires de ce
festival et on vous fait gagner des
places ce sont 20 places offert pour 10
concerts et 20 CD de la compilation
blues sur scène c'est à retrouver sur la
fiche qui est sur l'adresse qui
s'affiche si dessous merci encore Arnaud
allez une autre date musicale retenir
c'est le vendredi à 7 novembre à 21h le
prismaël en cours accueille le virtuose
de la mandoline Christine et le pianiste
américain Brad medlo pour un concert de
blues et de folk on reste on reste dans
la thématique tarif à partir de 21 euros
on passe tout de suite à la chronique
cinéphile
et comme tous les mercredis ce sont les
sorties ciné vous avez de spectateurs
éclairé au micro dès l'ONU one
j'ai bien aimé dans l'histoire des ours
c'était bien
et que ça parlait des ours et de leur
vie pas terrible j'ai pas accroché
j'ai pas trouvé le sens en fait du film
donc tout le monde attendait à ce qui se
passe quelque chose et en fait c'était
limite à certains moments il y avait un
certain malaise donc j'ai pas du tout
accroché pas tellement bien je trouve
que le
la trame du film est un peu
fascisante voilà donc j'ai eu vraiment
un malaise avec ce film c'est spécial
mais c'est plutôt bien
personnellement vraiment j'ai j'ai
détesté vraiment
c'est déjà dans un milieu facile
on veut bien voir que on tourne encore
au fantasme ça ne m'a rien appris j'ai
sorti un film inothentique ah oui j'ai
trouvé ça sublime vraiment très très
beau
c'est une très belle histoire une
histoire d'un amitié l'amour total voilà
très très bien interprété deux acteurs
formidables trois acteurs
les avis des spectateurs sont tranchés
et très divers et comme tous les
mercredis également le coup de coeur
d'un professionnel du cinéma ce soir Luc
bocand du ciné 7 d'Élancourt notre coup
de coeur aussi les 7 cette semaine c'est
évidemment l'incontournable interstellar
qui sort aujourd'hui toujours très
attendu les films de Christopher Nolan
avec Matthieu mcconauguet oscarisé que
on a pu voir notamment dans l'excellent
film mode donc un voyage de deux heures
49 dans l'espace dans un vaisseau
spatial absolument hallucinant à la
recherche d'une nouvelle planète pour
abriter les habitants de la terre qui
ont malheureusement massacré à l'heure
donc c'est un superbe voyage dans le
temps il faut prendre un petit peu le
temps parce qu'il durent presque trois
heures c'est exceptionnel un film de
trois heures grosse référence au cinéma
de stade les Kubrick et notamment à 2001
l'Odyssée de l'espace donc faut pas
s'attendre à tout comprendre Christopher
Nolan n'arrête pas de dire dans les
différentes interviews qu'il donne dans
les médias mais venez avec nous dès
cette semaine dès aujourd'hui participer
à ce voyage exceptionnel dans l'espace
aussi des sept
nous devons affronter la réalité du
voyage interstellaire
merci je t'aime pour toujours
et à noter enfin ce rendez-vous cinéma à
la maison de l'environnement de
Magny-les-Hameaux à partir de ce
vendredi 20h ni organisé avec les élèves
de seconde option littérature et société
du lycée de Villaroy Guyancourt et les
jeunes de cappado trois films en
projection sur le thème des super-héros
allez kiosque c'est terminé pour cette
semaine rendez-vous mercredi prochain
même endroit même heure toutes les
dernières informations culturelles et
dates à retenir sont à retrouver sur le
site du kiosque bonne semaine à vous et
surtout gardez l'esprit ouvert et
curieux